oh boy
my leftover food sure doesn't taste the
same the next day i wish there were a
way to level up my leftovers
i got you
okay
let's start with pizza it's such an easy
leftover to bring in but having weird
cold soggy pizza no one wants it there's
actually a few really simple tricks to
get the pizza just like you had it the
night before let me grab two things
paper plate glass of water i know this
seems weird but you're gonna take the
pizza put it on the plate and then put
it on the glass of water and then
microwave it in 30 second intervals so
the glass of water is actually going to
keep the bottom of the crust crispy and
the cheese is going to get melty without
getting soggy
[Music]
okay so check it out i microwaved it in
two 30 second intervals the cheese is
nice and melty the bottom is crispy it
smells amazing i mean this is like
just as good as last night on a nicer
plate just uh to make fancy next we're
gonna move on to the leftover sandwich i
have to say i wouldn't really recommend
bringing a leftover sandwich in for
lunch you're better off just making it
that morning assembling it at your desk
but if you want to do a leftover
sandwich there's a few easy ways to make
it a little bit better as you can see
the lettuce is
soggy the bread is getting soggy and
weird but if you take all the greens the
tomatoes everything off
and then you can actually re-toast the
bread which i know seems weird but once
the condiments are off it's no problem
let me show you how it's done
cutting board knife
so you can actually keep this tomato the
tomato is fine so i'm gonna go toast
these and reassemble okay bread is nice
and toasted
got some mustard
gum
tomato
i mean
it's like
good as new
let's talk about salad dressing your
greens the night before is just gonna
result in like weird soggy greens so i
would say always keep your dressing on
the side you can keep it in tupperware a
little container you could even bring a
bottle of dressing in just don't dress
it before you're going to eat it i would
say dressing has about 20 minutes before
the greens are starting to they're going
to start to break down and become mushy
the next thing is a really easy trick
you're just going to take a damp paper
towel and put it right on top of your
salad you can put it on the greens the
vegetables cheese proteins it's just
going to keep it really nice and bright
fresh crunchy you can do this the night
before the morning of whenever you have
this leftover salad
damp paper towel right on top
and then
put a lid on it
keep it in the refrigerator until you're
ready to eat
all right what do you think whoa
amazing thanks for leveling up my
leftovers
[Music]
you